We're going to go ahead and restart this just once more and we'll go ahead and yeah, awesome.
We'll go ahead and get started building with the Xanoagent.
But before we do that, Kelly, I do want to show the audience what we've already built
with the Xanoagent and we'll see some groups, we'll see some tables.
And if we click in the group here, our medical group, we'll see credit points
for our medical records, our patients, as well as our users.
And if we go to our tables, we'll see our medical record, patient, and user table.
So all of this already having been created through this Xanoagent, this big purple button
in the top left, I'll go ahead and click it and we can see the prompt I passed in.
Build me the basis of a HIPAA application.
So very bare bones, very basic.
But just prior to this, I'd created what we had just seen.
And now we're going to go ahead and pass in this prompt.
And I'm passing it in with the Xano and Google Gemini agent.
So if you want to go ahead and get started for free, just like me, go ahead,
head to Xano and start building.
And what we're seeing right off the bat is it's going to start searching the files.
It's going to start reading through our workspace.
It's also going to be making sure that according to the docs, it is building
the appropriate and correct syntax.
So unlike say the siloed nature of what we had previously with our, our agents,
or I should say assistants, our database assistant, our logic assistant.
Now we have a fully comprehensive agent that builds everything from your
APIs to your databases, to your middleware and more, because it understands
the entire workspace context.
Now, another very cool part about this is that it keeps the human in the loop.
So what we're seeing is this RBAC implementation plan.
We'll use the middleware attribute directly on the query block if valid.
And it gives us these options, uh, attach middleware to the API group level.
So it applies to all endpoints in a group, um, or use middleware dot
run inside the end point stack if valid.
So it's giving us just a couple of different options.
We'll stick with this and we'll go ahead and approve and then submit.
So again, keeping the human in the loop, making sure that we're aware of the
plan before it starts building.
Um, but another thing that I really, really just actually love about what
we've done here at Xano within this platform is we've brought the IDE
experience to Xano.
So like cursor, um, you know, like, uh, VS code, like any kind of IDE, we have
our file tree on the left-hand side and we can see with these green, uh, folders
here or files, I suppose, uh, we get to see what's added and here's the Xano
script and of course, this isn't always fun to see errors are never too fun to
see, but the really cool part about this is if it doesn't self correct, we can go
ahead and fix with the Xano agent here.
Now, another really cool part about this entire process is the ability to go
through the stack and see things visually.
And of course the campus to see how it's thinking, how it's building.
So all of these different kinds of, you know, visualizations
to understand your code.
Not only do we see it create, but we also see it update.
So these purple bits here, we'll see it update.
And the best way for especially middleware is to go into that Xano
script and see the middleware here updating.
Now it didn't self fix.
So let's just go ahead and fix it with this Xano agent.
Again, just another very powerful feature to ensure that your code is
going to work instead of just writing it and then trying to test it and it
erroring.
So, uh, we'll give it just a couple of moments and it fixed it and, um, it's
validating it now, uh, but we can see over here within our chat, it's just
telling us what it did.
So we're never really out of the loop, whether it's visual, whether it's text.
We just have the ability to, of course, stay on top of what it's producing.
So we'll review these changes.
We get this beautiful diff here.
We get to see the middleware being applied.
And of course, for any file, we'll see a big green chunk of
everything that is created.
Um, so it's going to have this precondition, making sure that the author
or that the user exists.
Um, and from there, it's going to go ahead and select the roles.
We're going to go ahead and, um, uh, let's see.
So it's saying that the user management, um, for admin only, let's say it's
going to be taking a look at the URL, uh, parameters.
So this is going to be, if it is, of course, coming from an external request,
so let's see how this works here.
We'll publish to our drafts.
And before we even begin real quick, our data, that's me as the provider, perfect.
And as a patient, we have Chris amazing.
We're going to go ahead now and head over to our APIs.
We're going to go ahead and, uh, let's go ahead and post a medical record.
So I'm going to select my auth token.
Chris's ID one, let's say is a visits and the content is healthy and cool.
So we'll go ahead and click run and we can see that it posted.
Uh, let's go ahead and activate this debugger and we can see that it's
actually going to go ahead and step through everything.
So, um, what it's going to do is it's going to check whether or not, of course,
we're an admin and, uh, then it's going to check if we're a provider and we are
a provider, so it automatically says, great, let's return that and create that record.
So we get to see our new record created here.
This variable is now returned in our response and in our debugger, we
have the ability to see this.
And so from beginning to end, at least with the Xano agent, it is very, very
simple and very, very effective at being able to do what you want.
So, um, and this is just, of course, the very first thing that we've done
with the Xano agent and in just a moment, I'll show you the CLI.